alright this is step six they've had a
solve a Rubik's Cube what you should
have at this point is a top yellow face
which is completed and is one solid
color and you should also have two
bottom layers which are also complete
this is a second to last step so there's
only one step after this so we're almost
there
what this step is going to do is it's
going to reposition these four top
corner pieces so that they're in the
correct orientation and the algorithm
which we're going to use is Right
counterclockwise front clockwise right
counterclockwise back 180 right
clockwise front counter clockwise right
counter clockwise back 180 and right 180
and it's a relatively longer algorithm
than previous steps so it might be a
good idea to write it down or to just
pause and possibly rewind the video to
go back and watch closely as I go
through the steps on the actual cubes
okay so in order to actually perform the
algorithm what we need to do is assign a
right a front and a back face because
those are the three faces which are used
in the algorithm so what you want to
first do is you want to look around the
cube on the top layer here you want to
look for two adjacent corners which have
the same color so these don't have the
same color this one's blue and this
one's red you don't want to pay
attention to this top layer edge piece
because that has nothing to do with this
algorithm so if we look around these two
are also different it's red and orange
and these two are also different if you
look at these two though they are the
same so when you find two adjacent
corner pieces which have the same color
those corner pieces designate this face
as the back face so this would be the
back face this will be the front face
and this would be the right face in this
case
now if you're looking at your cube and
you don't find two adjacent corner
pieces which have the same color
well this cube also if you look around
it also doesn't have two adjacent corner
pieces which have the same color so in
that case you can designate any one of
these side faces as the front or the
back face or the right face it does not
matter so let's go through the steps and
try the algorithm out let's do it first
on the cube that does not have two
adjacent corner pieces which have the
same color
okay so if we perform that move so it
doesn't matter which side you designate
as the back or the front so let's just
designate this as the front and this as
the back so if we do that move which is
right counterclockwise front clockwise
right counterclockwise back 180 degrees
right clockwise front counter clockwise
right counter clockwise back 180 degrees
and right 180 degrees what you'll then
notice if you turn the cube around is
that there are now two adjacent corner
pieces which have the same color in this
case their orange okay so if we take the
other cube now and we look at these two
adjacent corner pieces which have the
same color these are going to designee
designated as the back face now
as I said before so if I turn this
around this would be the front face then
because that's the back face and this is
the right face so if we perform that
move again right counter clockwise front
clockwise right counter clockwise back
face 180 degrees right face clockwise
front face counter clockwise
right face counter clockwise back face
180 degrees and right face 180 degrees
now if you look at the cube you can see
that one side is actually totally
finished this side is now in the proper
orientation as far as the corners are
concerned and so are these two sides now
it doesn't always happen that you have a
complete side F
you finish this move this might actually
have a different edge piece here so all
four sides might have what looks like
this face or this face so if we perform
it with the other cube right face
counterclockwise front face clockwise
right face counterclockwise back face
180 right face clockwise front face
counterclockwise
right face counterclockwise back face
180 and right phase 180 and we look
around we also have the same thing so we
have a complete side and we also have
three sides which are not finished okay
so once you have something that looks
like this or even if you have a
different edge piece in this position
you're ready to move on to the final
step